le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
afin de soutenir une agriculture locale
et durable
le département a mis en place depuis
2015 un dispositif d aide pour les amas
pays
ce réseau d'association entre
agriculteurs et consommateurs favorisent
les circuits courts de vente directe en
produits agricoles pays de qualité
rencontre avec trois associations qui
ont adhéré à ce concept là en train de
ramasser des carottes du coup pour
confectionner les paniers qui aura
livraison du coup cet après midi sur
saint pierre
tout commence avec mes carottes et des
cendres à ramasser doute les bus mais
aussi d'autres produits comme tous les
mercredis les membres de l'association
en terres indigènes préparent leurs
paniers fraîcheur le concept de ses
adhérents des produits biologiques et
variés qu'il distribue directement
consommateurs alors on essaie de
s'adapter aux saisons quand même après
on fait en sorte de proposer vraiment
même des légumes que les gens
connaissent pas trop peut-être les comme
les shoots à bagages hors d'eux n'avait
que les gens utilisent pas trop on
essaie de remettre au goût du jour et le
fait de faire ça dans les paniers du
coup ça ouvre les jambes un peu à manger
produits l'exploitation a ouvert ses
portes en septembre dernier au petit
tampon chaque membre y va de son coup de
main à l'origine du projet sébastien le
producteur chercher un mode de travail
plus authentique et plus convivial sa
part d'une exploitation départ qui
souhaitent se développer et être un peu
plus proches de celles de ses clients en
fin de compte
le but est aussi de pouvoir faire des
ateliers autour de ça pour faire
connaître des nouveaux produits des
nouveaux légumes recettes
ça me permet de voir sur du long terme
des gens participer à des activités
biologiques et le respect de
l'environnement et du terrain à voir des
produits de qualité du sébastien et son
équipe ont créé une âme à pays
les amas pays sont leurs groupements de
producteurs et de consommateurs
objectif créer un circuit court de vente
chaque association a son propre
fonctionnement de phrases creuses euros
à petite-ile l'areq l'association pour
le respect de l'environnement et du
cadre de vie travail ce concept depuis
15 ans tous les samedis
les adhérents de cet amas pays se
retrouvent sur un marché associatif le
circuit court et là c'est à dire que le
là des roms à venir directement auprès
du producteur chercher son produit or
nous le
le client ne s'appelle pas client il
appelle à des roms chez nous parce qu'il
a le nom et il a une fonction il a sa
place au sein de l'association on est
pas une quelque chose de purement
mercantiles les compagnies comment ça se
passe tout est écrit dessus
il ya différents dépôts pour les
panneaux et me le marché solidaire c'est
vrai réseau c'est une vraie communauté
qui ceux qui se retrouvent chaque samedi
matin de la buvette dont d'ateliers et
qui échange pour soutenir les amas pays
le département a mis en place en 2015 un
dispositif pour accompagner le
développement des associations une
subvention de 30 mille euros maximum et
la prise en charge d'emplois aidés il
faut rappeler que les amas pays est
initié par le département de la réunion
sous l'impulsion de la présidente madame
nassimah dindar avec pour objectif de
rapprocher le consommateur et le
producteur dans un lien de circuits
courts
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est donc de
rétablir ce lien ce lien social entre le
consommateur et le producteur et surtour
supprimer les intermédiaires
c'est l'essentiel de la culture
réunionnaise on retrouve à travers ce
concept c'est aussi pour le département
une façon de soutenir la production
locale
les produits locaux de la terre à
l'assiette ou non je pense qu'il ya une
prise en compte de la difficulté du
monde agricole va dire que c'est une
nouvelle révolution car la révolution se
fera par l'achat et si on choisit de
d'engager son argent
auprès de producteurs locaux travaille
bien avec qui on a des relations
étroites qu'on peut vérifier c'est ça
que nous recherchons un système qui
profite aux deux parties jean pierre a
fait le choix de livrer ses paniers
directement au domicile de ses adhérents
on va aller livrer un peu sur le tampon
et sur la plaine des cafres
j'ai pas beaucoup de clients gsm parmi
eux fred line adhérente depuis deux mois
la tamponnaise est très occupé par son
travail et n'a pas le temps d'aller au
marché c'est plus pratique pour moi je
trouve que c'est plus pratique et
ça me fait gagner du temps du coup est
aussi ça vient de l'agriculteur même ça
passe pas par des intermédiaires et
vincent met en valeur aussi dans
l'agriculture de la réunion ii
en moyenne il faut compter entre 10 à 20
euros pour un panier fraîcheur un achat
responsable est un premier pas vers une
agriculture solidaire et durable
[Musique]
les associations pour le maintien d'une
agriculture pays regroupe producteurs et
consommateurs
objectif favoriser les circuits courts
de vente l'insertion sociale dans une
démarche solidaire tout en valorisant
les produits péi de qualité en 2016 le
département à accompagner 11am à pays
sur toute l'île il propose un dispositif
dead de 30000 euros maximum pour leur
développement et la prise en charge
d'emplois aidés pour plus de
renseignements vous pouvez adresser vos
questions à hama pays
@ cg974 point fr au 02 62 94 41 06
[Musique]
m